bonjour joe natale quelles sont les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez sur la situation assez verrou
d'onet
écouter les rues se tiennent quasiment
la totalité de la ville on a pu voir des
vidéos postées par l'armée ukrainienne
de ces de ces combats qui ont lieu dans
le centre-ville de ces verrous donne y
est et on sait à quel point cette ville
est stratégique pour la suite de cette
bataille du dombass juste après c'est
vers audonienne de l'autre côté du
fleuve donne est illicite chante ce que
nous étions il ya quelques jours avec un
marc alameda oui pour tourner un
reportage ce sera la prochaine ville sur
la route des de l'armée russe ils
prennent ce verrou stratégique mais
juste après il y aura deux plus grandes
villes de plus grand hub militaires à
prendre pour avoir la totalité du
dombass et notamment les villes de
cramât tort ce qu est la viande ce que
vous les lignes ukrainienne les lignes
ukrainienne les délais les positions
défensives ukrainienne sons sont très
fortes et nous nous sommes rendus
également dans le nord dans le nord de
cette région du donbass eux prédisent
youm où là aussi les défenses
ukrainiennes sont bien décidés à
résister à la poussée russe nous avons
pu observer sur place des lignes où il y
avait beaucoup de temps qui est
également d'aider lance missile antitank
anti xa bonjour johnattan washington a
annoncé cette dernière heure de
nouvelles livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine
vous vous êtes rendu vous lisiez à
l'instant sur plusieurs lignes de front
est pouvait confirmer que ces armes sont
très attendus par les ukrainiens
ah oui très attendu et on peut
l'entendre vraiment sur tout l'est sur
toutes les lignes de front nous avons
été avec amara la médaille les
ukrainiens les forces du craignait non
vraiment l'impression que ces livraisons
d'armes pourrait changer le visage de
cette guerre pourrait leur permettre de
gagner cette guerre c'est en tout cas ce
qu'ils affirment on parle de lance
missiles anti chars américains les
fameux jav l'un et ils sont très
demandés nous avons vu pour notre part
beaucoup de haine l'osdh et des lance
missiles anti chars de fabrication
britannique mais déjà velin visiblement
pour eux pourrait changer la donne leur
portée et plus grande leur précision est
plus grande et puis il ya aussi les
lance-roquettes multiples des systèmes
de lance-roquettes multiples qui sont
très attendues voilà encore une fois des
désarmements qui pour l'ukraine pour les
ukrainiens le président zelensky il a
dit aussi pourrait réellement changer le
visage de cette guerre